Kourtney Kardashian and Kendall Jenner  sparkle in matching thong bikinis that's  a full dream come true the 38 year old  reality star in the 19 year old  Victoria's Secret model felt the breeze  on the high seas Thursday  super enjoyable baring their booties in  sequin thongs  Kendall was seen rocking this blue  swimsuit with a button-down over top  black shades and a messy bun in her hair  big sis Courtney killed it in pink with  matching Sunny's and a low ponytail  while the two were spotted sunbathing on  a yacht with their friends in can France  really cute  Gort was also seen getting close with  her new beau Eunice Benjamin the rumored  new couple have been side by side  throughout the kardashian-jenner girls  trip while ex-boyfriend and baby daddy  Scott Disick has been packing on the PDA  with actress Bella Thorne no offense to  you but no matter what you do I can't  change my life over it  [Music]